kim kardashian sa soeur kourtney
sylvester stallone ou encore l'ancienne
star de la nba dwyane wade tous ont
explosé leur quota d'eau huit cent
soixante dix mille litres de dépassement
dans cette propriété de sylvester
stallone rien que pour le mois de juin
cinq fois plus que la limite autorisée
880 milles litres pour kim kardashian
est un record de 2 millions deux cent
vingt-trois mille litres pour le
basketteur à la retraite dwyane wade
l'équivalent de 18500 baignoire quand on
y voir les gars on est chaud
je je je je perds du vally
torchon prend feu c'est pour moi
alors que les californiens vif avec des
restrictions d'eau et sont appelés à
installer des plantes désertique à la
place du gazon le mauvais exemple des
stars d'hollywood a du mal à passer ces
personnes doivent savoir que ce qu'elles
font ou ne font pas un impact sur
l'ensemble de la population l'eau est un
bien commun et calme marion geof en
termine avec sa traversée sur une plage
proche de calais
après 9 heures et 22 minutes d'effort à
seulement 23 ans la norme en devient la
française la plus rapide de l'histoire à
relier à la nage l'angleterre et la
france le record c'était pour moi
facultatif et s'était même pas quelque
chose qu'il suffisait
cela veut dire que j'étais capable de
nager 20 minutes deux mois assez et non
les moeurs 22 ans je reviens sur pas
celle agence japonaise des impôts qui a
lancé un concours nommé sac et viva qui
a pour objectif oui d'inciter la jeune
population japonaise à consommer plus
d'apple les jeunes sont invités
d'ailleurs à soumettre leurs idées de
slogans de design de méthode pour rendre
la peau le plus attractif c'est
surprenant mais l'objectif est de
répondre à la baisse de la consommation
depuis quarante ans les jeunes japonais
boivent de moins en moins d'alcool ce
qui fait rentrer beaucoup moins d'argent
dans les caisses de l'état et maintenant
quelle activité professionnelle exercée
vous j'ai contrôleur des finances
publiques
malheureusement et oui vous le savez
c'est la loi alexis passe au rouge
je suis désolé vous avez été caster
aussi ça veut dire que vous avez
sélectionné des candidats et à l'entente
alors malheureusement pas avec vous
j'aurais adoré les oreilles sur trois
émissions oui ah oui c'est ça c'est vrai
mais caster de gas emissions raconté un
dîner presque parfait
du docu j'ai fait du c'est ma vie j'ai
fait un buzz tellement cher j'ai fais tu
sais ma vie j'ai fait dans alger faits
dont tu pleurnichard aussi un j'ai fait
dans du muscle et qui se déshabille et
qui est très bête exactement non c'est
vrai ah ben oui
oui sans mains pleines
[Musique]
mais laurent soit intelligent bien que
je te raconte pas devant la télé va
faire un tour un des gages comment
dégage que je te fasse pas la honte
devant des caméras dégage c'est mieux la
fois intelligente avec ton cerveau de
pois chiches là le neuf
complètement inculte
[Musique]
débile ça rentrait pas
dans le casting on se dit ok là
maintenant il faut qu'on prenne
quelqu'un qui soit vraiment bête alors
on va pas jusque là mais on va dire que
si on peut tout à fait sentir petits
moments du mais qu'ils y j je le dis où
je ne dis pas un dîner ou un peu poussé
les curseurs un peu loin d'accord ok il
existe vraiment par contre oui les
jambes est oui oui
il ya même deux régions c'est indiqué
besoin de savoir jusqu'où ça a été un
besoin de ça pour
soulager
me dis que nous mettons
enfin on dit imbéciles heureux et je
crois que quand même
c'est que plus on est plus on est
heureux voilà qu'est ce que vous voulez
que je vous dise
vous
votre cabinet au niveau national un
poste sur cinq n'est pas pourvu en
maternelle ou en élémentaire contre à
peine un sur vingt l'an dernier
même constat pour les collèges et lycées
un poste sur cinq restent vacants
certaines matières comme le latin ou le
grec sont très impactées presque quatre
professeurs sur 10 lorsqu à l'appel
c'est un poste sur trois en physique
chimie et en mathématiques mais le pire
c'est en allemand un post sur deux n'est
pas pris contre un sur cinq l'an dernier
ah ah ah ah ah
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
thierry marx il y avait une critique à
faire sur ce plat une prédication se
placer agaçant
agaçant parce que c'est tellement bon et
c'est tellement professionnel que fait
par des amateurs c'est agaçant pour le
professionnel que je suis c'est
délicieux très bien